[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
jury selection begins in the pike county
massacre some of these jurors even start
off
reversing the presumption of innocence
and disgraced attorney alex murdoch
returns to a south carolina courtroom as
attorneys argue over the evidence
prosecutors say connects the defendant
to the 2021 murders of his wife and son
plus was this jury able to reach a
unanimous verdict on all 11 counts in
this case listen a verdict is handed
down in florida in the kidnapping and
attempted murder trial of trevor summers
and later a closer look at the parkland
school shooter's childhood years he
didn't really blend in with the other
students he stayed apart
on in the classroom law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm your host mike sacks in for brian
buckmeyer now the final phase of jury
selection is underway for one of the
wagner family members charged in the
pike county massacre george wagner iv is
accused of conspiring with his brother
and parents to murder eight members of
the rodent and gilly families in april
2016. lawn crimes anjanet levy is in
pike county ohio with the story
70 prospective death qualified jurors
reported to the pike county courthouse
on monday morning this is where final
jury selection is beginning death
qualified means it's already been
determined that these jurors are willing
to implement the death penalty if it's
warranted so the final jury of 12 will
be selected from this final 70. cameras
are not allowed in the courtroom for
this process george wagner iv was in
court with his lawyers picking the jury
that will determine whether he's guilty
of conspiring to murder eight members of
the rhoden family and hannah gilli his
lawyers wanted the entire panel stricken
in a motion wagner's lawyer said that
working-class jurors had been excused
citing financial hardship which was
discriminatory and not fair to wagner
and that the panel of 70s skewed heavily
toward women 51 of the 70 are women 19
are men judge deering denied the motion
the defense wants somebody who's not
going to automatically think just
because somebody's charged that means
they're guilty jury consultant alan
turkheimer said wagner's lawyers may
look for someone who's had a family
member who was wrongfully accused or had
a negative experience with the justice
system as for the state a good juror for
the prosecution
is somebody who defers to authority
somebody who thinks that
too many
defendants get off because of
technicalities in the law they believe
that if somebody is charged they're
probably guilty the rodent and gilly
murder investigation is the largest in
ohio's history with four crime scenes
the probe took investigators from ohio
to alaska and montana
jake wagner and his mother angela are
testifying against george and his father
billy jake and angela said in court that
they carried out the murders so that the
family could have full custody of the
daughter he shared with hannah rhoden
after the jurors are seated they will be
taken to the four crime scenes where the
rodents and hannah gillie were murdered
they will also be taken to other
locations that were searched during the
investigation for law and crime daily
i'm angenette levy
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and criminal defense attorney nicole de
board now nicole it's not often that
jurors have an opportunity to visit the
crime scene so how do you think this
will affect the jurors on the case
i think it will weigh heavily on them it
will have the effect on them of being
where the crime occurred obviously which
is very emotional they'll have an
opportunity to
be in the same location breathe the same
air really feel the presence of all of
the things that ultimately will be
talked about in court i think viewing
the crime scene in a case like this can
have a huge impact uh usually in favor
of prosecution yeah and terry two of the
four wagners have already admitted to
their involvement in the crime how do
you think that will affect this trial
it's going to have a huge impact mike
because listen those two individuals are
the mother and brother and they're
testifying against george and the father
and so i think when you have two family
members testifying against two others
it's really going to make the jury stop
and think listen this has to have
happened the way they are saying it
happened it's an odd set of
circumstances for four people to
conspire to kill eight people but that's
exactly what happened here and now
they're all pitted against each other
and i do think because jake is
cooperating if they get a conviction
against george and ultimately father
then they will be spared the lives and
so i think that the evidence is very
very strong i think there will get a
conviction here
i absolutely think they should probably
do a plea deal because of all the
evidence against them it's a waste of
the county's money frankly at this point
but we'll see what happens yeah terry
you'd mention spared lives right because
i believe jake he's spared his own death
penalty in this case for for life in
prison successive uh successive
sentences whereas here george iv it
might be risking his own life with the
death penalty should he ultimately be
convicted so it is a fascinating
potential big deal of a case of course
it's already moving forward jury
selection is happening and we're going
to see where it's going to go we will be
covering it online crime as well now i
do want to turn to only fans model and
instagram influencer courtney clenny
she's back in florida being held without
bond over the april murder of her
boyfriend christian obamacelli now
kalani known as courtney taylor to her
more than 2 million social media
followers was in court for her first
appearance saturday in miami her
attorney is arguing there is not
probable cause for a second-degree
murder charge now clenny is accused of
stabbing obamacelli to death in their
miami apartment april 3rd though she
initially said she threw the knife at
her boyfriend prosecutors argue
obamacelli's injuries suggest the knife
was powerfully thrust downward which
sliced a key artery near his heart clint
is claiming the stabbing was done in
self-defense the couple's relationship
was reportedly constantly abusive
officials released a video of the two in
an elevator shortly after cleny's arrest
in hawaii of the model hitting
obamacelli now cleny is set to be in
court for an arraignment on wednesday
switching now to sports legal news where
buffalo bills punter matt ariza is
released amidst an ongoing gang rape
lawsuit over the weekend it was
announced that arizo would be released
from the team just two days after a
civil lawsuit was filed against the
punter according to the lawsuit ariza
and two of his former san diego state
teammates raped a then 17 year old high
school senior back in october 2021. the
lawsuit alleges that then 21 year old
ariza took the girl to an off-campus
party at his home where she was raped
for an hour and a half
the three men are accused of rape gender
violence and false imprisonment on
friday arizona released a statement
reading in part quote the facts of the
incident are not what they are betrayed
in the lawsuit or in the press i look
forward to quickly setting the record
straight
in more nfl news washington commanders
running back brian robinson jr is shot
in what police are calling a possible
attempted robbery or carjacking it
happened on sunday in washington d.c
officials say two suspects ran off after
the shooting and officers later
recovered a firearm nearby a
spokesperson for the metropolitan police
department says robinson suffered two
gunshot wounds to his lower extremities
and was taken to a local hospital for
treatment a statement released by the
washington commanders reads in part
quote he sustained non-life threatening
injuries and is currently being treated
at the hospital where team officials are
on site with him we ask that you respect
brian's privacy at this time now still
ahead on long crime daily just hours
after the defendant presents his own
closing argument a florida jury hands
down a verdict but first disgraced
attorney alec murdoch appears back in
the south carolina courtroom as lawyers
argue over the evidence which led to
murder charges for the deaths of his
wife and son
[Music]
welcome back disgrace south carolina
attorney alec murdock back in court
monday for a hearing involving the
murder charges in the 2021 deaths of his
wife maggie and their son paul this
comes after murdoch was charged in his
wife and son's murders last month more
than a year after they were shot and
killed on the family's property the
investigation into their deaths led to a
slew of investigations into the
disbarred lawyer's finances he now faces
more than 80 charges for alleged schemes
to defraud former clients of more than 8
million dollars earlier this month
murdoch's defense attorneys requested
prosecutors disclose the evidence
against their client claiming they'd
received none of it which was delaying
and hindering their legal defense a
south carolina judge ruled all evidence
must be shared with the defense but
issued a protective order saying the
defense is restricted from releasing or
sharing any of that information before
the ruling the hearing erupted into a
shouting match between the defense and
the prosecutors
we're here for the state's motion
taken away
we're not here for that we're here
because
[Music]
on this case i'm sorry if i feel upset
but i can tell you that every time we
turn around they're trying to hide
something what i find as a right to a
fair trial and a fair trial means a
motion
as of now a trial date is set for
january 2023 but terry alec murdoch has
been accused of multiple crimes but the
most serious of course is the murder of
his wife and son so what do you think
was his motive
you know i think that is the
million-dollar question i think he's
killed them because he's covering up
other crimes remember there were lots of
bodies found in and around him stephen
smith that's the one i think people
don't really recall he was a 19 year old
his body was found not too far from
their home in 2015. then of course the
person who worked on their estate gloria
satterfield she was the former
housekeeper her body she died in 2018
and they said that that was an accident
and then mallory beach died and she died
in a boat that was driven by paul the
son so i do think that he probably
killed his wife and son because he's
trying to cover up these other crimes
maybe they knew about it obviously paul
was involved in the killing or the death
of mallory beach and plus he's got all
these other charges the fraud the money
laundering the forgery and i'm sure he
had conversations with his wife and so
perhaps he thought he could silence her
in that way so i think it's to cover up
all the other things that he's now
currently dealing with with these
charges bodies everywhere this is some
baroque stuff still of course innocent
until proven guilty nicole the
defendants accused of multiple crimes
including embezzlement and now murder so
there's so much here is there something
where an incentive defense could come
into play i think it's definitely
possible i mean look you know these are
his own family members that he's accused
of killing his child his wife
and whatever the reason
if it's true that he didn't deed kill
these individuals there can't be a good
one and there has to be some sort of
mental defect here that plays a part
into what he was thinking or exactly
what it was he was trying to accomplish
here so it's definitely possible
yeah in january 2023 again is when the
trial is set to begin the lawyers are
already at each other's throats it seems
perhaps uh gonna be contentious one
moving forward but still coming up
online crime daily it's week two of the
defense's case in the parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial plus a
verdict is handed down in the florida
trial of trevor summers after
representing himself against the charges
of kidnapping and attempted murder of
his estranged wife
[Music]
welcome back a florida jury returns a
guilty verdict all across the board
after a week of testimony in the case of
trevor summers who represented himself
against kidnapping and attempted murder
charges summers was found guilty late
friday night of kidnapping attempted
murder sexual battery child neglect
grand theft of a motor vehicle and
violating a domestic violence injunction
in march of 2017 he was accused of
holding his estranged wife elisa
mathewson captive in her own home and in
the backseat of her suv for three days
during that time he attempted to kill
her twice once with a pillow and a
second time with a rope summers was also
charged with child neglect after asking
his then 14 year old daughter to open a
window at elise's house so he could get
in and having her drive her four
siblings to his house 12 miles away he
faces a possible sentence of life in
prison his sentencing is set for october
late friday night the verdicts for all
11 counts were read in court
we the jury finance follows asked
account one
the defendant is guilty of attempted
murder in the first degree that's the
count two
the defendant is guilty of attempted
in the first degree that's the count
three
the defendant is guilty of kidnapping as
charged
as the count four
the defendant is guilty of sexual
battery by a person 18 or older upon a
victim 18 or older as charged that's the
count 5.
the defendant is guilty of sexual
battery that's to count six
the defendant is guilty of child neglect
as charged that's the count 10.
the defendant is guilty of
grand theft motor vehicle as charged
that's account 11.
the defendant is guilty of violation of
domestic violence injunction as charged
so sailing
guilty on all accounts now nicole
defendants of course have the right to
self-representation but do you think the
judge should have allowed summers to
cross-examine his wife
you know if a person is representing
themselves they get to do the things
that a lure would ordinarily get to do i
will say as we have heard from these
verdicts
the jury doesn't usually like it
when the accused is questioning people
uh who are victimized by the conduct in
question
and you know a lot of times they even in
jury selection question potential jurors
who i have seen recoil at this sort of
behavior so
generally a terrible idea a person who
represents
a fool for a lawyer no question yeah and
terry the jury then of course found
summers guilty on all counts as charged
do you think they got it right here
oh that all-male jury got it absolutely
right no doubt about it i wasn't worried
so much about the kidnapping and
attempted murder charge i thought that
listening to alisa's story might have
that charge come back guilty the child
neglect also because as you mentioned
mike he had his 14 year old drive over
20 minutes to a destination of his home
and frankly that's dangerous but i was a
little bit worried about the grand theft
auto i thought that they might think
that it was a car it was driven by the
husband at some point in time so it
wasn't theft but as it turned out they
believed her story entirely he violated
that domestic violence injunction and he
sexually battered her and she said that
on the stand she was adamant that he
raped her she said this is the very
definition of rape you broke into my
home you woke me up you forced me you
tied me up so i thought that that would
come back and i'm glad that that jury
saw it that way and i think that it was
unanimous on obviously every single
count and that was the right decision
yeah and it was of course a hail mary
for the representation for himself when
it came to cross-examining his ex-wife
but of course the jury could have found
similarly had his lawyer also gone for
the cross-examination there as well so
you know you would never know which way
which way it went one way or the other
but if we do know how it went in reality
and it was guilty as charged on all 11
counts now when we come back we head to
florida for the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial give the testimony
from the shooter's elementary school
teacher who describes his demeanor in
his early years
[Music]
welcome back monday marks the start of
week two as the defense presents its
case the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial in february 2018 the then 19
year old gunman opened fire at marjory
stoneman douglas high school in florida
17 people were killed and 17 more
injured in october of last year the
gunman pleaded guilty to all charges
that means it's now up to a broward
county jury to determine whether the
defendant is sentenced to life in prison
or is given the death penalty last week
defense attorneys began their case
focusing on the defendant's troubled
childhood and upbringing on monday
jurors heard from one of the defendants
elementary school teachers and she
explained he mostly kept to himself but
had violent outbursts
nicholas was
very quiet
he was aloof
he um
he didn't blend in well
with the other students
i'm trying to think
anxious very anxious
he was very much when he had his
belongings in the
classroom he knew where they were he did
not want to share so those
behavioral problems could be
throwing things
correct yes it could be hitting people
correct yes it could be destroying
property yes but we're talking about if
they were older if they were adults if
they were out on the street
those would be crimes wouldn't they
they could be yes okay because you can't
destroy people's property right you
can't hit people
right
so nicole do you think the teacher's
testimony there will help the
defendant's case and if so how
i think that it might i think that the
defense has done an incredible job of
trying to personalize cruz i mean so far
what the jury knows without the defense
case is that cruz is the monster that
committed these horrible horrible crimes
uh and without giving him a childhood
and a family and a background that's all
they would ever know so i think that the
defense is very smart to call these
witnesses and it is giving us a bigger
picture of him as a human being and not
just a defendant
yeah terry because for the last many
weeks we've been hearing about how cruz
was did and thought and behaved all
sorts of terribly up of course including
the murders at parkland at the parkland
high school
but here we're hearing a different side
of him and all the jurors said that they
could vote for the death penalty if the
evidence supported it but what are the
chances of unanimous verdict for the
death penalty after hearing from the
defense
you know saying that you can vote for
the death penalty is very different from
actually casting those votes and nicole
is right when you listen to all of those
mitigating factors it gets difficult at
the end of the day you realize and
recognize that he had a very difficult
childhood he didn't get a good start his
mother did not take care of him in the
womb she was on drugs she was on alcohol
and he didn't act well in class he had
behavioral issues no one gave him the
help that they are all now testifying he
truly needed so i do think that these
jurors are listening to that and it's
going to have an effect on them even if
in the beginning they thought they could
vote for the death penalty and so the
other issue here is some people think
that life in prison is worse than the
death penalty and they may say to
themselves look i was going to vote
unanimously for the death penalty but
now i'm thinking these crimes are so
horrible let him just sit in jail and
then there's always the possibility of a
stealth juror who told everyone doing
vardyr yes i can vote for the death
penalty but at the end of the day they
had no intention of doing that for
personal reasons which is fine but you
are supposed to excuse yourself for that
yeah terry and nicole thank you very
much for your commentary here today in
your analysis well worth listening to
everything you had to say thank you for
joining us here on long crime daily as
well everyone watching and we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you